interested in that are you in what
Halloween party
well this is what it is we're dressed as
the devil no that's what we're doing is
it well hey you'll get you might win the
damn prize trying to you know get us a
little dj get us a roll of ring and you
know have it so have a good night but
like I said you're more than welcome or
what I'm sure if you invite the coaches
they'll be there you think they would
okay if you don't want them no no no no
no no it's the opposite because it's
like for instance Halloween I mean we
don't go out no more right you know what
I'm saying right but we still have that
it's a great holiday yeah
so we're candy in costumes yeah right
wow